yeah the Sun explodes and we're living
in internal darkness this is what's
going to save our life
oh it's might start blowing your hair mm
it's nice and cold on my scalp this is
possible it's a burning no it's not why
is one eyebrow a different color than
the other there's no rules and glove you
look like a Miley Cyrus extra you ready
okay do my hair lights up all right give
us the food oh nice this looks
radioactive when you peel it it's kind
of interesting did your mother never
tell you not to play with your food yeah
but she never said don't play with your
glow-in-the-dark food Cheers mmm tastes
futuristic definitely tasting Neon miss
this is the only time I would advocate
eating with your mouth open
this tastes sweet I would eat it in
outer space
hmm let's just look though wait are the
chips glowy
I actually don't do meat or dairy like
neon dairy it doesn't really tell you
okay go on my mouth
it was probably frozen but not really
because it glows in the dark it's crazy
how much like seeing something though
can affect the way you taste that is
true I can't tell if it tastes good or
not a taste doesn't matter it doesn't
even look like it used to be like these
play-doh kitchen sets you can buy where
you put a bunch of play-doh in there you
squeeze it out it comes out like
spaghetti that's exactly what this looks
like this looks like Nickelodeon slime
this is delicious like I'm ready to
consummate my vows I just hope it
doesn't constipate my bow like my senses
are all scrambled up yeah I feel like my
intestines are glowing and I wonder how
it's gonna come out later glow in the
dark makes everything more fun and less
flavorful I was more interested in
playing with the food than actually
eating it for me is just fascinating to
be like the way something is presented
to me will alter the way that I taste
yeah underneath the black lights it's
like yeah I would eat that all day yeah
just cuz it looks cool I'm just waiting
for those microwaves and spy kids where
you just put like a bean in and then it
comes out cheeseburger